everyone I'm Scott and this is a game
spot news update publisher blizzards
annual convention doesn't officially
kick off until tomorrow but one of its
big surprises may have leaked a little
early game informer reports that
retailer gamestop has received word that
multiplayer shooter overwatch is coming
to playstation 4 and xbox one previously
the game was only confirmed for PC all
versions of the game are priced at sixty
dollars and the slated to launch
sometime in 2016 according to the report
we've also seen speculation that
overwatch could be a free-to-play game a
blizzard representative told GameSpot
quote we are excited to share more
information about overwatch with
everyone at slizz con this weekend so be
sure to tune in to the opening
ceremonies if an official announcement
is coming at blizzcon we won't have to
wait long the annual event begins
tomorrow november six with an opening
ceremony at 11am pacific daylight time
we're also expecting to see the first
trailer for the upcoming warcraft movie
at some point during the convention so
have you had a chance to play overwatch
is closed beta and so let us know what
you think in the comments and either way
stay tuned gamespot for more blizzcon
coverage all weekend long